bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
cette semaine dans le kiosque vous allez
découvrir l'exposition sortie d'atelier
à guyancourt
nous partirons en escale à plaisir pour
un week end méditerranéen
enfin nicolas gervais nous présentera la
chorégraphe maria mendy mais pour
l'heure face à l'invité
après les scènes parisiennes il foule
les planches de la royale factory à
versailles jusqu'au 12 juillet avec son
spectacle sébastien j'irai passe à l'
orange humoriste auteur et comédien
bonsoir sébastien giray consorts alors
vous êtes rhinois originaire pourtant de
lyon vous avez fait des études de droit
expliquez nous comment vous en êtes venu
à la comédie alors j'ai commencé par
faire du droit a sorti de mon bac
puisque c'était la voix qui me semblait
la voie normale d'études normale entre
guillemets qui me semblait la plus
adaptée à moi et donc j'ai commencé j'ai
commencé le droit pour rapidement de me
rendre compte
après quelques échecs et puis une
motivation un petit peu limité que en
fait c'était pas ma voie et que qu'il
fallait que je fasse quelque chose que
j'aime vraiment et puis le théâtre j'y
pensais un petit peu quand j'étais plus
jeune mais vraiment je trouvais ça sympa
bien mais c'était pas vraiment un métier
vocation oui mais c'était une vocation
et puis jamais j'aurais pu faire je me
voyais mal annoncé plus tard je ferai du
théâtre à dire sans les parents elle et
puis non je sais pas pour vous mais moi
non
et puis finalement bon le droit j'ai
fait mais j'ai fait deux ans à la fac et
puis j'ai pris la décision de leur dire
en fête papa maman finalement je pense
qu'il faut que je fasse un truc que
j'aime vraiment puisque c'est pour toute
la vie donc je vais faire du théâtre
donc là ma mère l'a plutôt bien pris et
puis mon père je les réanimer puis ça
s'est passé après il est donc finalement
ils m'ont sauté puis ça ce sont les
premiers mes premiers supporters ils
vont ils ont vu le spectacle 25 fois il
de kenneth parker d'ailleurs parfois mon
père comprendre prendre ma place quand
je suis malade
oui
alors des références non j'essaie
justement ne pas trop me rapprocher
d'eux d'untel ou d'untel ont parfois on
me dit ah ya un peu du semoun et un peu
dit dubosc j'apprécie bien sébastien
giray moi j'essaie de faire un tiens
quand un petit jeune plus tard on dira
tiens toi tu fais un peu du gier est ce
serait effectivement ce que j'essaie de
faire de me distinguer d'avoir une
propre îles hautes
c'est quoi alors mon humour je dirais un
humour un mélange de absurde de d'humour
noir et de jeux de mots si j'aime bien
un petit peu de jeu ne nous faut pas
trop en faire venir un peu lourd
sébastien giray passe à l'orangé
alors moi ça me fait penser au juge pas
vous êtes un peu borderline provoquant
alors effectivement le passage orange ça
rappelle le côté borderline à la limite
et puis il ya d'autres significations ce
que t'es pas ça l'enjeu c'est un peu le
fil conducteur du spectacle où je donne
plein de signification de ce terme passé
à l' orange et est donc c'est un humour
voilà qui est un petit peu rentrer
dedans
rosie tableau corrosif du camp voilà par
l'intermédiaire de personnage vous avez
une galerie de personnages
c'est un spectacle que vous travaillez
déjà depuis six sept ans exactement
exactement dont on peut dire qu'il est
très très bien rodé maintenant alors
justement on va regarder tout de suite
un extrait du sketch la rupture pour me
faire pardonner d'être en retard un
autre anniversaire de deux ans sont de 3
ans ans
j'ai quelque chose à te dire pour notre
anniversaire de 2,3 ensemble qui je
pense ne va pas te laisser indifférente
je te trompe avec sylvie non pas sylvie
du monocle l'autre si lui ce nom là
sylvie ta petite soeur sylvie ça te dit
quelque chose
tu peux pas me faire confiance tu
troupes
je suis en train de te raconter toute la
vérité ça veut bien dire que tu peux me
faire confiance
le j'ai toujours été honnête avec toi
nathalie dès que tu pue de la gueule je
te le dis si tu t'attaches à des détails
à ce moment là moi non plus je peux pas
te faire confiance
ton régime ultra diète
1 tu sais les régimes qui m'a coûté la
peau du cul là alors qu'il était censé
haute et l'excès de gras du tien
mais tu devais perdre 5 kilos en une
semaine quand l'avez perdu que 4 à ça
veut bien dire que pas menti bon bah
gigot et puis je t'appelle tu te rendre
ton appart et tout ça tu veux que je te
dépose quelque part en voiture sur mon
chemin
bah allez on va faire ça ah mais non je
suis belge et de l'essence que pour une
personne à rester spectateur le savent
pas mais vous vous étiez en train de
rire en voir garde à vue ça vous fait
mal et je me regarde pas souvent en
vidéo donc ce personnage aurait reconnu
le personnage du mec sympa un poil
misogyne
bon j'ai pas remarqué ces quads et des
situations vit réellement vécu ou des
gens que vous avez rencontré enfin alors
pour construire un personnage qui est
des situations de vie de vie réellement
vécu des personnages que j'ai vraiment
rencontré mais un personnage que je joue
n'est pas un personnage que j'ai
rencontrés c'est une synthèse a rassuré
nous aider c'est pas vous quoi vit
maintenant à un ami à moi je suis the
gentleman zee alors justement rien un
panel de personnages est-ce que parfois
vous rencontrez des difficultés on a vu
là celui ci voilà un peu misogyne y
beaucoup de cynisme
est-ce qu'ils avaient des difficultés
d'interprétation alors ça peut être
aussi peut-être physiquement il ya des
routes peut-être plus physique que d'eau
dans l'image qu'ils véhiculent
oui il ya deux personnages notamment qui
sont un petit peu plus alors y en a un
qui est un peu difficile à jouer parce
que c'est un directeur d'école
cocaïnomane qui obligé de rentrer dans
la drogue pour supporter ses élèves et
donc celui ci et je me laisse la liberté
de l'interpréter de façon différente à
chaque fois
parce que c'est difficile de jouer un
drogué
vraiment habitée quoi je si jamais je le
joue pas bien ça va tout de suite autant
on va regarder tout de suite parce qu'on
a aussi un extrait donc dix cas d'école
et cocaïne alléluia
j'ai corrigé vos copies sur vos rêves
d'avenir il ya quatre copies ses ventes
du site
vous avez accompli déjà ça avec la coke
qu'on fait de l'argent
qu'est ce que tu viens bien à jean
patrick va ta mère la
alors déjà jean patrick sache que ya pas
de sot métier et j'espère c'est valable
pour tout ce que vous utilisez des
préservatifs
enfin c'est pas parce que c'est
maintenant qu'il faut faire confiance
apparemment sur lui par sur le parking
tu lui aurait écrasé le pied avec son
bolide
bien sûr que tu n'as pas fait exprès tu
y aura dans le point et je défie
seraient les pneus ta chaise roulante
jusqu'à ce soir
tu m'as l'air dans une forme
paraolympiques rigueur rigueur rigueur
rigueur petit con prochaine fois je te
retires quelqu'un pour prendre
l'ascenseur alors vous a vu également
vous avez remarqué par anne roumanoff et
c'est sheridan qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter encore pour la suite
on peut me souhaiter d'avoir un succès
ormis images de ce spectacle on peut me
souhaiter de faire du cinéma
parce que c'est aussi ça serait
l'objectif final ça serait bien c'est ça
le truc que j'ai peint auquel j'ai pas
encore accédé en effet les cours florent
on l'a pas dit oui qui vous a permis
aussi justement d'écrire tout votre fait
date
voilà de me former dans acting vous
faites quelques séries télé et vous
animer une émission pour les jeunes sur
canal vous êtes jeune public voilà nos
gagné matters télé théâtre je joue dans
une pièce de théâtre aussi qui autres
comment spectacle et talent perdre à
votre arc
voilà il manque cette petite corne
cinéma bat avis aux réalisateurs en
attendant pour vous voir basse et
jusqu'au bout juillet donc à la royère
factory tous les samedis merci beaucoup
c'est aussi pour leur détention
merci direction à présent la salle
d'exposition de guyancourt qui accueille
jusqu'au 19 juin
les oeuvres des ateliers d'arts
plastiques de la ville une opportunité
pour ces artistes amateurs de présenter
leurs oeuvres au public
peintures sculptures gravures ou encore
photographier les 130 oeuvres présentées
par la salle des expositions de
guyancourt ont toutes un point commun
elles sont réalisées par des artistes
amateurs de la ville sortie d'atelier
exposition annuelle des ateliers d'arts
plastiques guyancourt toit est
l'occasion pour les enfants et adultes
participants d'exposer leurs travaux
réalisés pendant l'année
ça fait une dizaine d'années que
l'expulsion sortie d'atelier clos
toujours la programmation de la salle
d'exposition d'ennemis en cours ça
représente vraiment la variété de toutes
les pratiques amateurs à guyancourt
cette année on en particulier on a la
chance d'avoir des oeuvres de d'enfants
qui sont en fait qui ont travaillé sur
la ville ce sont des fresques
collectives
au total 42 adultes et 44 enfants
exposent leurs oeuvres et pièces uniques
découvrir jusqu'au 19 juin
nicolas gervais est parti cette semaine
à la rencontre de la chorégraphe maria
mendy est nous présente son spectacle
non pas d'un thé pas nos pas dans tes
pas c'est le nom de ce duo chorégraphié
par maria mendy suite au décès de son
père un duo qui sera présentée le 24
juin à la ferme de bel ébat agri en
cours avec le spectacle qu'à 1 de
sébastien perrot dans le cadre d'une
soirée consacrée à la famille voici donc
maria mendy dans le kiosque
chorégraphe et danseuse j'ai monté ma
propre association
l'association jade en 1996 et depuis ça
fait que évolué j'ai pas mal d'élèves
dans des styles différents danse
africaine hip hop afro jazz break j'ai
monté au sein de cette association à
l'atelier chorégraphique avec les
danseurs qui me suivait le mieux
cassure est aussi le mieux on a passé
pas mal de concours etc
où on a été lauréat souvent et puis du
coup j'ai décidé monter une compagnie
manger
m
le duo il a été
il a été pensé au moment du décès de mon
père a fait il ya un certain que ça va
faire deux ans le théâtre de belles et
bam appel en disant voilà moyen d une
proposition à le faire ce que tu aurais
quelque chose a présenté au théâtre
sauf que cette proposition arrivait pour
moi pas au bon moment parce que j'étais
vraiment pas bien par rapport à cette
histoire et je me sentais pas capable
j'avais pas envie de créer quelque chose
de noir raconter ma vie par rapport au
décès de mon père et en même temps je me
suis dit purée c'est une super
opportunité le théâtre je peux pas
passer à côté
voilà je leur ai demandé de me laisser
un peu de temps j'ai répondu ok mais ce
serait une création
concernant le décès de mon père
en
pour pouvoir la créer j'ai beaucoup
écrit ce que j'avais dans le coeur et
gégé j'ai fait un petit peu une marche
arrière sur le parcours de la fin de vie
de mon père jusqu'à jusqu'à son
enterrement et je me suis dit qu'est ce
que j'ai envie de faire donc j'étais
rentrer vraiment dans cette démarche les
moments à l'hôpital les semaines qui
passent ses espoirs de c'est bon il va
s'en sortir
et puis cette fin tragique comme une
grosse claque qu'on prend comme ça et on
hésite il pue la cua vécu là et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui en fait je pense que j'ai du
mal à l'accepter
voilà mon père c'était le pilier de la
maison c'était l'africain dans toute sa
splendeur
en tout
on
qui
mettre en scène au niveau de la
gestuelle c'est difficile parce que je
voulais pas non plus trop rentrer dans
quelque chose de mon père il est mort
pour tout le monde le sache
c'est pas arrivé qu'à moi et j'avais
envie d'ouvrir ses portes aussi à ceux à
qui
c'était arrivé du coup ça a beaucoup
évolué au niveau de la création
alors oui je vais le travailler avec ma
soeur n'a pas pu se faire
je le dis elle attend un bébé en fait
donc fallait que je reparte avec un
autre danseur mais j'avais besoin que ce
soit un danseur de deux proches
quelqu'un qui connaissait la famille g
saisir danseurs qui me suit depuis des
années lionel tony key et breaker
notamment donc l'amener dans mon univers
autre que que le break
ça a été difficile mais en même temps
c'était très enrichissant enrichissant
et pour lui et pour moi donc ça va pas
être un spectacle de hip hop de break
mais plus vraiment travail de recherche
par rapport à toutes ces influences que
quand je connais que je peux maîtriser
comme l'afro jazz la danse africaine le
hip hop que je pratique voilà après nos
pas dans tes pas nous retrouvons la
danseuse étoile de la rédaction aurélia
découvrons à présent vos sorties au
micro au t2 10 mois ne sortent ici n'est
pas bon c'est un film superbe qui montre
bien les romands pourraient dire les
problèmes et enfin tout ce qui a pu se
passer pendant la guerre et voilà
c'était bien démontré un très beau film
sur pression lager sur l'amitié sur le
pardon de ce qu'on peut faire pour la
guerre excellent film que je vais
recommander très bon acteur n'apprécie
la halle le déroulement du film
voilà donc à recommander creux parfois
vulgaire un film de nana je pense
qu'elles se sont fait plaisir on se
reconnaît pas ce que c'est gai les
histoires de filles mais bon il n'y a
rien d'extraordinaire passé on l'a vu on
voulait le voir aussi un petit peu amusé
mais c'est tout ça peut paraître un peu
simpliste mais c'est pas mal
il ya une
une bonne énigme c'est bien moi j'ai
bien aimé j'étais un peu déçu j'ai
trouvé qu'au niveau des je pensais
qu'ils auraient plus plus d'action
ces trucs c'est un peu un peu plein donc
le film est extraordinaire à tous les
niveaux c'est un policier à wismes
policiers et ici on est au coeur de la
chine m'a semblé et au niveau de
l'interprétation d'une part mais aussi
de l'image est une idée par seconde par
plan alors dans la chronique cinéphiles
vous le savez nous vous faisons partager
l'avis d'un professionnel du cinéma et
cette semaine c'est bertrand pigné
responsable du cinéma les yeux d'elsa à
saint cyr l'école qui nous présente son
festival pour le jeune public les yeux
pleins de des toiles
cette semaine au cinéma les yeux d'elsa
je vais vous parler de quelque chose qui
se passera à partir du 18 juin c'est un
événement que nous organisons tous les
ans depuis trois ans c'est un festival
de cinéma vers le jeune public et leurs
familles alors ça aura lieu du 18 juin
au 28 juin
c'est un moment où vous allez pouvoir
retrouver les grands les grandes
héroïnes du cinéma celle de votre
enfance et puis de l'enfance de vos
enfants ou de vos petits-enfants
vous allez retrouver blanche-neige
coraline kiki nausicaa pas thema mais
aussi cléo la grande héroïne de
agnès varda modane et bien d'autres
encore le premier grand événement de ce
festival se déroule le samedi 21 juin
c'est un grand moment au milieu de notre
festival puisque nous allons présenter
l'avant première du film le garçon et le
monde
un film brésilien de l ol groupe qui
sortira en octobre qui est vraiment une
très très belle fable entièrement
musicale accessible à partir de 6 7 ans
qui sera suivie d'un goûter
le dimanche 22 juin nous proposons un
ciné concert sur le film le mécano de la
général de buster keaton qui sera
accompagné en direct à la guitare
électrique et aux effets sonores ça se
déroulera à 14 heures donc le dimanche
22 juin le lundi 23 juin nous proposons
une ciné-conférence alors la spa s'est
pas particulièrement pour les enfants il
n'y a pas de raison qu'ils ont vécu pour
les enfants sur le film cléo de 5 à 7 de
agnès varda qui est un des uns des
grands monuments du cinéma français un
grand moment du démarrage de la nouvelle
vague un très très beau film que j'aurai
l'honneur de vous présenter
et puis nous allons vous proposer
également une soirée animations avec
pathé mahé le monde inversé nausicaä de
la vallée du vent et after school in
lighters ça ça aura lieu le vendredi 27
juin et y aura pour jusqu'à 2 heures du
matin mais je sais que vous êtes
courageux et que vous serez nombreux
et puis pour finir une
une journée de clôture le samedi 28 juin
où nous aurons le plaisir d'accueillir
quelque chose d'un peu spécial un
spectacle qui sera proposé gratuitement
qui est accessible à partir de 2 ans
c'est une forme relativement courte un
spectacle d'ombrés accompagné
musicalement par un musicien sur scène
et puis une comédienne chanteuse qui
vont raconter des histoires à partir
d'objets qu'ils vont transformer grâce à
la lumière sur scène de vente vous
devant vous je vous invite à venir
nombreux ça risque d'être quelque chose
de mémorable
et pour finir en beauté nous proposerons
peau d'âne le film de jacques demy qui
ressort dans quelques jours en copie
numérique restaurée
donc nous l'aurons en avant première
avant sa ressortie et nous vous
proposerons le samedi 28 juin à 18h30
pour finir dans un univers plein de
couleurs et de fantaisie
voilà c'est donc le festival les yeux
pleins d'étoilés à saint cyr l'école du
18 au 28 juin
vous trouverez tous les renseignements
sur notre site internet sur le facebook
de la ville de saint cyr l'école et sur
le blog jeune public du festival et du
cinéma les yeux d'elsa
allez je vous propose à présent d'autres
idées de sorties c'est prochains jours
alors venez découvrir trappe sous un
angle historique au cours d'une balade à
pied une première visite qui vous
plongera dans la ville d'avant 1980 et
ça se passera samedi à 4 le 14 juin à 14
heures le rendez vous est au cinéma le
grenier à sel pensez à réserver
également le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines vous dévoilera
l'envers du décor d'un spectacle
appareils techniques machinerie lumière
ainsi que la révélation des plus beaux
détails des architectures du bâtiment ce
sera mardi 17 juin à 20 heures
de la même façon pensez à réserver
auprès du musée de la ville voilà le
kiosque c'est fini à mercredi